eh bien le fameux cellulaire dans les
classes vous savez peut-être qu'à partir
du 4 novembre prochain les élèves en
ontario ne pourront plus la portée tout
autre appareil mobile personnelle non
plus donc seulement s'en servir
alors la récré à l'heure du dîner aussi
la france va plus loin elle est bénie
carrément dans tous ses établissements
scolaires d'où notre question ce matin
qu'il est la place des fameux cellulaire
dans les écoles j'en parle avec thierry
karsenti qui est titulaire de la chaire
de recherche du canada sur les
technologies de l'information en
éducation donc à lui verser de montréal
ce qu'arsène simon jour bonjour il ya eu
ce sondage en ontario qui révélait le
nie pas c'est là que presque la totalité
des parents sondés les enfants aussi 80
17% étaient en faveur de restrictions
des cellulaires à l'école est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce que
l'ontario fait bonne route ou fausse
route en interdisant cellulaire écouté
selon moi c'est un problème complexe
mais la simple interdiction c'est faire
fausse route
le cellulaire les technologies les
écrans c'est un grand problème de
société et je pense que la mission de
l'école ce n'est pas uniquement
d'interdire c'est vraiment des ducs est
d'amener les jeunes à se responsabiliser
maintenant l'idée d'avoir des règles
c'est important mais parfois derrière
l'interdiction on oublie d'éduquer et
c'est peut-être là la grande erreur
qu'on risque de faire donc vous dire
vous êtes en fait qu'il ne faut pas
bannir complètement le cellulaire de la
classe mais plutôt encadrer l usage
c'est ça les âges et comprendre que
c'est un grand problème c'est pas
uniquement un problème chez les jeunes
en france ils ont interdit jusqu'à la
huitième année environ
et qu'est ce qui se passe à 9e année
actuellement utilisent son cellulaire
n'importe comment aussi et donc je pense
que devant ce problème complexe il faut
s'asseoir il faut rechercher des
solutions mais il faut travailler à la
responsabilisation des jeunes
travaillent à la formation des
enseignants qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
en cause quand on a des jeunes qui sont
appelés par toutes ces notifications et
les jeunes
à moins qu'on fasse des fouilles dans
les écoles vont risquer de les apporter
vous savez on dit que ces permis à la
récréation qu'est ce qui arrive entre la
récréation et celle de
en soi ce que sera le cellulaire mais
plusieurs la question qui se pose est
donc ce sera facile je pense pour
certains jeunes en tout cas d'avoir la
tentation de dissimuler sur eux de
l'avoir en classe plus discrètement de
façon moins ouverte
est ce qu'ils seront plus attentifs pour
autant du tout expliqué les règlements
pour la direction les directions d'école
l'application du règlement sera
diffusera complexe sera différente
qu'est ce qu'on fait en cas de
manquement mais encore une fois l'idée
les règles de son importante le
cellulaire en place est un immense défi
pour les jeunes ils ne l'utilisent pas
de façon méchante les messages textes et
les notifications sur les réseaux
sociaux snapshot instagram et c'est ça
leur fait vraiment ils sont extrêmement
sollicités par ça devant ce problème
complexe on interdit je pense que
l'école ne remplit pas sa mission
l'école à travers le canada
sa mission est d'éduquer d'instruire
socialiser et simplement interdire le
téléphone moi je pense qu on fait fausse
route
ce serait quoi alors la meilleure façon
d'encadrer un usage des cellulaires la
première une des premières choses c'est
de tenter de travail et la
responsabilisation des jeunes de leur
montrer dès le primaire avant même
qu'ils aient l'âge d'avoir un appareil
cellulaire
quels sont les bons et les moins bons
usages vous savez le téléphone
cellulaire c'est plus puissant que ce
qui a permis à neil amstrong d'atterrir
sur la lune de processeurs et plus
puissant on donne sa des jeunes sans
manuels d'instruction et on est surpris
après de leur mauvais usage moi je pense
que dès le primaire il faut travailler à
l'éducation des jeunes à l'éducation
médias à l'éducation écran bon usage et
d'écrans au mauvais usage parce que ces
mauvaises usage on ne livre pas
uniquement chez les jeunes envoient des
adultes en réunion on travaille on voit
des adultes au restaurant dans la rue
qui sont chacun sur leur téléphone
cellulaire est ce que c'est ce qu'on
souhaite comme société je ne pense pas
et donc devant ce contexte devant ces
défis que pose de téléphones cellulaires
de trouver des solutions ou l'école
participe activement à l'éducation des
jeunes me semble beaucoup plus
intéressant mais par exemple de façon
encore plus concrète insulaire cnce et
j'aimerais vous entendre à savoir un
enseignant de français ou de
mathématiques
comment ils pourraient encadrer l'usagé
du cellulaire et pendant qu'ils donnent
des explications aux élèves il ya
plusieurs façons on ne fait plusieurs
recherches avec mon équipe sur l'usagé
cellulaire en salles de classe et la
première chose qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que le problème
il est grand il est présent c'est un
problème de chacun mais maintenant on
diabolise beaucoup de cellulaires vous
savez les parents dans le sondage qui a
été fait en ontario son compte
mais qui est ce qu'ils achètent le
cellulaire à l'enfance et aussi les
parents alors c'est quand même là il ya
quand même une interrogation avoir sur
les résultats de sept ans ok parce que
c'est pas le jeune en général qui
lui-même doit pouvoir se procurer le
cellulaire cela dit dans des cours de
mathématiques de français les bons
usages qu'on a pu voir ce sont des
enseignants qui parfois vont issue aussi
utiliser le cellulaire à des fins
éducatives
dans les écoles on se plaint souvent
qu'il y ait un manque de ressources
technologiques
le cellulaire c'est une ressource
intéressante pour les enseignants
comment faire il faut être conscient que
les jeunes l'ont il faut leur permettre
peut-être parfois de l'utiliser à des
fins éducatives
d'autres fois il faut trouver des
stratégies pour les amener ranger leurs
cellulaires et ne pas la voir avec eux
et l'énergie il est là le 10 mai mais le
met le mettre dans une boîte à l'entrée
ils vendent même des kits maintenant des
espèces de chaussettes numérotés où les
cellulaires sont rangées de dents et on
les remet france et le temps et ça ça
fonctionne relativement bien et ça prend
une ou deux minutes et puis c'est très
rapide
l'idée c'est on l'enlève par moments on
leur donne par moments des fins
éducatives et tranquillement on
travaille à la responsabilisation
il ya aussi des applications qui
permettent de bloquer l'usagé de façon
temporaire donc il ya une panoplie
d'outils nos lui de regarder ses
solutions et de de travail et finalement
pour trouver la meilleure solution selon
frontex l'interdiction finalement c'est
comme on interdit quelque chose on pense
que le problème va se régler le problème
est juste reporté à plus tard et encore
une fois on est loin de notre mission la
mission des écoles s'est pas uniquement
de bannir c'est pas une prison l'école
vraiment do travailler à l'éducation si
c'est un problème de société
le téléphone des écrans sens large moi
je pense que l'école doit travailler de
façon plus éducatif que ça donc c'est un
défi de taille qui s'ajoutant faut le
dire quand même déjà des situations très
complexes auxquels font face à bien des
enseignants on le sait on va suivre
comment ça va se passer en tout cas
l'application de ce règlement là
en ontario et voir également ces ados
province qui vont y aller avec des
directives en ce sens c'est thierry
karsenti
merci merci vous conseille ce matin